the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay but I thought I would do is go I'm
going to go quickly through the problems
that were assigned for practice there's
seven or eight of them I'm not gonna do
with all of them I'm gonna go through
and kind of talk about so it's some of
the key issues are with each problem and
so the you know maybe make some points
about identifying how you do problems
not necessarily specifically focus on
the exact question that was asked here
so here is this first this was a quiz
from last year and you are asked to find
an equation of motion for this thing and
it's it can be a bit of a puzzling
problem so how many degrees of freedom
what are the constraints what equations
should you use so first of all I look at
a problem like this is it planar motion
or not okay
so maximum three degrees of freedom what
are the what are the constraints though
so G is are over two from the center so
that's true and so it's it what you're
really saying is it's fixed in radial
motion right then you're right that's
one so that's one constraint what's
another constraint in this problem how
many of you wield how many degrees of
freedom do you expect to end up with how
many equations do you need how many
coordinates Isis one right so how do we
articulate the other constraint so it
can't move radially we figured that out
so this is a this is actually kind of an
important point in this problem because
if you get this down then the problem
becomes very simple so talk to a
neighbor what's how would you describe
the other constraint here I'm gonna give
you a way to give you a hold it a second
pardon well there is gravity yes but as
gravity is not a constraint so this is a
pendulum actually of sorts but
describing things to talk to a neighbor
and what how would you describe the
other constraint
okay how would you describe it what's
the other what's the other constraint
here so sometimes if you have sometimes
if something's pinned we say well then
it's fixed in X&Y
and that's two constraints it's only
left to rotate but this one doesn't seem
to it's kind of hard to understand where
this one's pinned you know this thing is
constrained in X&Y cuz you want to use
theta for the coordinate right but how
do you say that it's constrained in that
other thing yeah okay okay so he's
saying that you can define x and y in
terms of R and theta and that's that's
true and I'm gonna say it slightly
differently so the way I think about
this problem is we've said that it's
constrained in the radial direction so
that's why it can move in the tangential
direction right this problem is really
exactly the same as the skateboard
problem in a bowl okay just you shorten
that thing a little bit and it looks
like a skateboard and we're ignoring the
inertia of the wheel so it's just a
stick sliding up and down so what's the
relationship between the tangential
motion and theta is it a fixed
relationship so how far does it move in
the theta you know if you have a little
motion Delta Theta how far does it move
it tangentially our Delta Theta right is
the you know the Delta are tangential
the distance it's moves so this this is
a way to say the other constraint is if
you know that theta
you know how far it's moved in the radio
in the tangential direction so that's a
way of saying that other constraint okay
then we can say we completely described
this problem by one one coordinate and
that
data and the second you can do that this
problem then has a center of rotation
right right in the center of the circle
and anytime you have a body which
rotates around a central point then you
know that you can describe the angular
momentum of the body as sum i with
respect to a times and it's planar
motion so then it's just Omega C right
long as this is a principal law here
usually just you have the mass moments
of inertia in terms of principal axes
here and it's nice when you can write it
that simply right so soon the second you
can identify a fixed point about which
something rotates then the angular
momentum simplifies to that okay and
then this problem of course the sum of
the torques with respect to at the
center here that's got a me D H with
respect to a DT plus VA o cross PG oh
but this is what's the velocity of point
a Sara so you don't have to worry about
this term and it's just that and you
know that the sum of the external
torques and this problem comes from
gravity so you put in the gravity term
and compute the torques about the center
so our object really looks like that and
here's G and in the problem the way it
was posed the theta is drawn from this
line this is beta
so what's the moment arm looks like
whatever this distance is which is our
over to it's given R over 2 cosine theta
there's a length of this side so the
moment that gravity makes is some mg and
that's gonna be equal to some i ZZ about
a theta double dot okay good let's take
a look at the next problem edit now so
my intention here I'm gonna go kind of
quickly one by another that I'm just
trying to hit the important concepts so
if you have a question about the
concepts asked you know if I've left you
wondering this is I really want this to
be kind of a conversation here so that's
the whole point of giving you the
essence of what these problems what
makes these problems work ok this one we
just find a location of the center of
mass your I think you're pretty good at
that sort of thing with respect well
remember there's a couple points about
center of mass this one it says find it
and you're given the two objects
important point is that you can pick any
coordinate at all with in order to use
it to compute the center of mass I pick
s here the m1 and some distance down
here is where the center of mass is that
we're looking for and so this is the G
we're looking for
so m1 plus m2 is the total mass times
the position of G of G I guess it ought
to be a capital S G here must be equal
to the sum of the parts times their
positions m1 s G 1 plus M 2 s g2
and you can solve for s G and that tells
you where you're at so you can pick any
coordinate at all to calculate it and
once you find it you know where it is
okay so you just solve here for s G it's
that divided by the total mass obviously
okay
the next question was draw principal
axes so is this does this object have a
have some planes of symmetry do tell me
one slice down through it this way okay
and that means you have a principal axis
where perpendicular to every plane of
symmetry so you have a principal axis
coming out of the board that's one and
you have any give me another family
plane of symmetry yep this one so that
means you've got a plaintiff axis
principal axis going that way and so
then the third one has to be
perpendicular to that so you have one
this way this way and this way
so it asked for so if this is G then
principal axes with respect to G one
there one coming out of the board and
one going up like that so what is it
just remind yourself what it means for
some to be a principal axis so if you
have if you know the principal axes of
an object
if you rotate and and you've chosen them
to go through G do they have to go
through G do all principal axes have to
go through G no not at all the principal
axes just have to give you when you work
it out a diagonal inertia matrix right
so
but what does it mean for to have be
have body coordinates and we know our
principal axes well one of the things we
know that if you rotate about G rotate
about a principal axis passing through G
if you rotate about any one of them is
it dynamically balanced guaranteed you
must rotate about the principal axis
though if you now I'll ask you a second
question if you rotate about any axis
passing through G is it statically
balanced right
if you rotate about any axis passing
through G is it dynamically balanced
maybe right not necessarily it might be
dynamically balanced if you pass through
G and it is a principal axis right okay
can you pass through a principal can you
have a principal axis not going through
G and rotate about that axis and have it
be dynamically balanced yeah okay
so we'll we'll talk we'll talk about an
example in a second okay so I think
there the second question here said okay
we want to rotate this about this point
G to now G to is right in the middle oh
this is this body that's where its
center of mass and there's a g1 up here
that's the centre of mass of the upper
body and there's a composite centre of
mass right here which we just computed
what it was and that we want what's
there's going to be an axis pass through
or axis of rotation passing through G 2
and we're rotating this body around it
so first question is this axis coming
through G 2 is it a principal axis yes
if we rotate about that axis only do you
expect it to be dynamically balanced all
right do you expect it to be statically
balanced no and let's
so we're spinning it around this this g2
going like that around key to it someone
make it Z we know that this is g2 we
know that G for the object is here
that's the center of mass of the whole
thing so there's some distance between
those two which I don't know but we can
figure it out we'll call it e so what's
the force required at this pin that it's
axial it's going around what's the force
required to allow this thing to spin
around to hold it there since the other
force required to hold it in place and
you and I don't intuitively have an idea
of what it is why is it a forest of may
think to to spin around this central
axle there's a force required to keep
that thing from moving away what is it I
hear centrifugal okay so you're
accelerating the center of mass of that
thing you're making it go in a circle
mass times acceleration is a force and
you know that's the tension in the
string when you're swinging the ball
around this is no different from
swinging the ball on a string and you're
essentially calculating the tension
required to keep that thing from go
flying off and we could probably just
guess if we can almost guess what it is
you know minus the total mass times the
acceleration which is inward that's
where the minus comes from and what is
it louder
Omega squared I'm here on Omega Z
squared we need something else
pardon yeah they are they are is this
will eat here it's called the
eccentricity when you have something
unbalanced Omega squared and it's in the
R hat direction we'll call it in words
and the in words is the - so that's the
acceleration mass and accelerations the
force this is also you could compute
this by computing D by DT
a P of G with respect to O and you with
you that's then m1 plus m2 times V of G
and you have to take the D by DT of it
and that gives you that which is the
acceleration so the forces you get
directly from computing DP DT if you
need to remember a way to do that all
right
so conceptually I'm going to if I don't
know what E is I don't want to have to
figure it out can I so I'm going to
describe you a way in which you could
get directly at this answer which
reminds us something about angular
momentum and these bodies this object is
made up of two objects and we're
spinning at about the center of one of
them so let's take them one at a time
how much force is required to keep this
spinning about that axle that goes right
through its mat center of mass none why
right because there's no R Omega squared
there's no acceleration you're not
making the center of mass of this object
you on a circle so this piece of the
doesn't enter into the solution the
actual force the mass of this mass here
is it it's in two in the problem m2
doesn't actually have anything to do
with the answer because it's perfectly
statically balanced around that point
all of this force making a thing going
on circle is making this piece go in the
circle so in fact this force up here is
minus m1
and now we need the distance from the
axis of rotation to its center of mass
well that's um our we need to know what
that r is and I think that's basically
this is L over 2 and this was B plus B
over 2 so the distance from this
rotation point to that center of mass it
L over 2 plus B over 2 Omega Z squared
mass this is acceleration and it's
inwards and that's the total force okay
all right let's look at the next problem
Jason can you pull up the next one
okay this problem this problem and the
next are rather similar this is the
elevator problem with a pendulum in the
elevator it's a couple subtleties here
the elevator you're told that it's
moving upwards at some particular rate
of acceleration some Y y double dot
that's given so how many degrees of
freedom does this problem have yeah okay
two or one I hear one I see it too how
many coordinates is gonna take to
completely describe the motion or how
many equations of motion do you think
you're gonna need
I see ones and two so a little not
little too okay if we know the
acceleration of the thing and we you
know start with some initial conditions
at time zero it's sitting on the ground
at y equals zero and now it takes off
from the first floor we know for all
time its position so that's actually
that's actually a given it's a specified
thing and we don't have to write in a
separate equation of motion for that to
have that we then we'll have to solve
right so it's actually it's given so the
actually only dynamic equation of motion
we have to write is about the pendulum
now will it involve y double dot
absolutely but it's at a given number
it's just a number of your Gary you
don't have to write a separate equation
of motion so this is actually you got
was just one degree of freedom yeah okay
so you want to put up and put up the
next problem that one so this problem
has how many degrees of freedom this is
definitely two because you don't know it
is the motion in up-and-down though of
the mass and the slider with a spring on
it is an unknown you're gonna have to
write an equation of motion that which
would have to be solved to get it so
so a distinction a subtlety that can
trip you up when your specimen the
motion is actually specified and you
know what it is for all time you don't
need a separate equation for that so
this problem requires two the behavior
of the pendulum part is essentially the
same in in both when you write the
equation well let's talk about how will
we go about solving this problem we need
two equations two coordinates what would
you pick for your coordinates theta and
then a coordinate this one I guess it's
called Y so Y for the square block
sliding up and down and a theta for the
pendulum right two equations of motion
and to get the Y equation of motion you
would use we're not using the garage
here we're going to do a little review
of direct method what how would you
write the equation of motion using up
there I can't I wrote the that's the key
to everything that we do with the direct
method sum of the forces sum of the
torques every rigid body has at max how
many degrees of freedom six for rigid
body completely at planar motion this
reduced to three but every rigid body
and in 3d space has six degrees of
freedom
three positions three rotations so you
write some of the forces on the body
that is equal to mass times acceleration
that gives you three equations one in
each vector component direction you
write the sum of the torques that's also
a vector equation you can get as many as
three equations out of it if you need it
then we keep reducing down how many
equations we need to get by figuring out
the constraints until we get down to the
number of actual degrees of freedom and
that's that's the remaining equations
and the number of equations you actually
need so this one it requires two and if
you're going to write an equation of
motion about the main root that mass
that slides up and down what law would
you use yeah some of the forces is equal
to mass into acceleration then we need
to get another question what's the what
law would you use
second one torque about where talk about
a okay so let's look at that so that's
the second equation up there torque
about a is the time derivative of the
angular momentum with respect to a plus
that V a cross momentum term which gets
to be which is a little annoying to work
out so the simpler version is the third
equation it's a pretty quick derivation
to go from that second equation to the
third and it it's much less work
generally to get that mass times
acceleration term a lot less work
actually and if I've got time I'll work
out I'll go back and we'll work out a
problem like this and we'll we'll do
that part but let's go on to the other
questions okay
this problem two rigid bodies
is it planar motion right how many
possible degrees of freedom for each
rigid body times to six
now how many constraints so let's take
him one rigid body at a time the big
roller pardon know why she says okay
that's one constraint in it to two
possible things left ah so I think this
one's no slip so how is what it had is
no slip then give you a constraint right
so are there's an R X equals R theta or
minus R theta depending on how you
define the theta right so they are we X
is not independent of theta and that's
the second constraint so you only need
one equation one generalized coordinate
to describe the motion of wheel and what
would you use okay so theta you could
you say two or you could use X sorry and
now the other object how many
constraints does it have now what are
they what are the constraints on the
t-bar
okay
he says that's true let me give you a
little hint about how I process this
when I'm looking at it remember when
you're trying to when you're picking the
generalized coordinates they need to be
independent right an independent means
if you freeze all but one that last one
can still move okay
so we've picked one you said theta or X
let's freeze it
what motion is left of that T bar you
can only it can only rotate right and
that means it has a pin that point up
out at which it rotates which you have
just fixed so it's constrained that pin
constrains it in how many directions to
right off the bat you have the two
constraints right at the pin but it's
not so obvious until you say let's
freeze that other coordinates and then
we see that aw there's only one possible
motion left the rotation okay so we have
a rotation and a translation or two
rotations that's the way we could write
equations of motion if we did
translation of the main disk what what
equation would you would use to write
the equation of motion for the main disk
force yeah Newton's second law
all right some of the forces in what
direction can only move in horizontal
yep so some of the forces in the X
Direction some of external forces in the
X Direction equals mass times
acceleration
now this though has some problematic
external forces right come from what are
they the difficult ones
well friction there's a friction force
and and there's also the internal forces
at the pin right so you getting into
sorta had it work your way through that
so you don't want to mess with the
external forces at the pin
you have to just some room so you gotta
some rotations at the yeah so this this
problem is no escaping something messy
so I would say so let's say we're going
to do or the one equation will be the
sum of the forces on that main roller in
the horizontal direction and that's
going to force us to deal with a
friction force and an internal two
reaction forces at the pin
well you just write them down then go
and write the same expression that's sum
of the forces on the other object and
it'll also show up with those two
internal forces you add those two
equations together those forces cancel
okay and that gives you the first
equation and it'll involve acceleration
of both masses and you'll have to figure
out the acceleration of that second mass
around its own but you know how to do
that that's just kinematics and then you
got to do the torque equation and you'd
probably do it about a and this does
this involve what about the velocity of
a in this problem is it zero no until
you may have to deal with that second
term and again I would go use the third
expression because that you need to find
the accelerations anyway and I would use
that yeah
some of the talks about then D is the
point of contact yeah and you would get
at mainly the that would give you a way
of getting at I think an equation of
motion it mostly describes the big
roller I don't know I've never in terms
of the other one I'm not something that
then talking about the second rigidbody
I don't think I would do it you get that
gets a little complicated but it's
interesting it might be worth a try okay
I'd probably do it about a it's the
point I would choose and deal with the
fact that you need to know the
acceleration of a but in this problem
that's pretty that's it's pretty
straightforward what's the acceleration
of point a in terms and let's say our
horizontal coordinate is is X what's the
acceleration of point a X double dot in
the I direction pretty easy to stick
that in this third expression up here
and you know our G with respect to a is
just the half is just the length of the
distance down to the center of mass of
that T so that terms pretty easy to
figure out and then the lead term is
just everything with respect to G and
that's pretty straightforward okay good
how are we doing on time not a lot left
and is that the last problem yeah
yeah its friction ultimately well
friction ultimately end up in this in
the answer to this one no well is
speaking in Lagrange's it do any work I
know but you know about it now right
constraints they do no work if I usually
don't end up in in the final answer I
don't have a simple way of just
explaining why it doesn't but if in the
first case we instead of doing some
amounts Newton's law on the first one we
had done torques about D it would have
given us an equation of motion for the
roller and then you could have done
torques about a a different equation it
would have got equation motion largely
dealing with the T you still have some
internal forces and torques that you're
gonna have to eliminate so this is not
not a simple problem not a simple
problem but straightforward if you know
what lost you apply so some of the
forces some of the torques and be
careful with the extra term this if this
object were just given an initial
deflection like that t-bars picked up
and let it go and it's a certain it's
just Donuts thing what can you say about
the center of mass of the system
well it doesn't not yeah it's not that
it doesn't necessarily move but it
doesn't what what if in well us put it
this way what if I gave this thing a
push to start with and now it's gonna
roll along huh
okay this is the Senate if that in that
case you're saying that the center of
mass moves with constant velocity and
Newton would agree with you why
because once it gets rolling is there
any friction force so you got to draw
the free rider grab gram and decide
whether or not there any forces on the
system if there are no external forces
on the system Newton says no
acceleration no change in momentum so
once you get it rolling there's actually
no friction force because it isn't
trying to either speed up or slow down
the rolling so and it goes to actually
to 0 is there slip
no it wasn't slipping but he's happily
rolling along there are no external
forces acting on it means the mass times
the acceleration of the center of mass
of the system is zero so the center of
mass does not accelerate it means it has
constant velocity now if I contrived to
have the initial velocity of the center
of mass be zero just cause that thing to
swing back and forth what would you see
the center of mass do has no net has no
linear momentum linear momentum of the
system is zero since the center mass
sits still he doesn't it's velocity now
is zero there's still no acceleration
it's just this t bar is rocking back and
forth right so what must the roller be
doing so the roller has to move to the
left when the T bars going to the right
and so the two things are going like
this and the center mass wherever it is
it's just sitting still okay all right
there our last problem this is a pretty
this is but this forces you to go back
to the fundamental definition of you
know angular momentum you know it's our
cross this little summation of each RI
cross P I and add them up and you get
the angular momentum with respect to
that rotational point one degree of
freedom has the center of mass where is
the center of mass of the system can you
describe it
somewhere in between the two masses
right the two point masses center of
mass would be someplace in between so
once you figure out where that is then
you can concentrate all the mass there
and and go from there does this have
mass moment of inertia it does can you
write and it was the equation of motion
it's just a pendulum can you write I
about a theta double dot equals minus mg
something sine theta there's if you this
is a pendulum yeah a restoring torque on
it comes from gravity and you and you
have to be you will end up with an
expression that looks like some eye with
respect to the point of rotation so
basically you just need to figure out
what is i with respect to a and it is
there particles so as each particle has
an eye with respect to its center of
mass it's equal to for a particle
concentrated point mass yeah but there's
no arm so I about a pie for a particle
about its center mass is zero is that
okay so this only has parallel axis
theorem components it has M one time
just distance squared from the center
plus M 2 times this isn't scared from
the center and that's the total i ZZ so
then you can write it out okay so I
think we're run out of time